welcome to this video where I'm playing
Carlton no not Magnus some guy with
simpler name is rated to two to two and
nine from the UK and we have an open
Sicilian and someone wanted me to play
the English at Tech so let's do that so
I don't really know it's there's some
point in playing this first or long
castles hmm I think what black is doing
here is not so great actually
but obviously I'm not an expert on on
the opening the combining this early
Bishop e7 and Bishop seven I think it's
quite suspicious at least it's not Wow
create five really
Queen a five and B five rarely works
together in the Sicilian okay right five
so should I play a form on them probably
I should use the momentum check going
for f5 here I can consider to take with
the pawn yeah and I will do that
it's simply um it's a play strengthens
my my Center okay so f5 or is this too
much let's let's graph first it says
this is actually good I can just improve
pieces first before I do any anything
radical okay
okay if I take twice he's going to play
before so the silicon has at some point
but I can I can I can actually take
before Bishop g7 takes on c3 Bishop c3
Queen somewhere to c7 probably and then
I grab I grab the rook takes b4 Bishop
g7 takes on tc3 Bishop c3 Queen c7 take
on h8
funny okay let's do that maybe you could
have played up Jade now that I think of
it
this I don't really believe I mean I
really I just can't take this look my
king is wide open
but long castles is just one more away
and did some quite save after that it
once yeah okay can do that but this is
just material down as well okay the burp
here Queen check now maybe just this one
preventing the check and he can exchange
but this is just completely lost the
endgame three points down and yeah okay
this is just just the lost endgame
it's opposite colored bishops but three
pawns and
capital of rooks on the board so
okay great I was thought he's thinking
him up troupe t3 Rock t3 bishop before I
forgot about that one yeah this is
stupid
hmm
how silly is that okay come on I know
this isn't really necessary but even
this is winning get the edge pawn and
then the H pawn my H bone is is marching
down the board
yeah completely unnecessary of course
so look h7 look somewhere and then the
h-bomb pushes I mean supported by the
bishop on c3 and he's got no counterplay
whatsoever this is the most important
thing
his rooks don't get active so this is
actually simpler to play then to to not
offer to not sacrifice the exchange I
cannot really cover h7 in the first
place
hmm so now he's letting the clock wound
down still trying to to find some
defense I can't play Roxy for Roxy for
and grabbing it for but it's not really
helping much
yeah I also have g7 or just quite good
besides taking on an f7 but immediately
pushing the pawn to g7 it's not not bad
I go rook age eight he can take on c3
and take on g7 so I better use my pawn
as well
age six rook age eight and then promote
yeah I'm checking the exchanger or this
wasn't wasn't the best but it's still a
pretty a pretty straightforward win just
stopping this pawn black resigned
yeah of course I just a completely
overlooked a bishop before I could have
played that basically any move here I
just blundered that but the the exchange
stack here is just a straightforward
when I'm picking up all bonds
yeah compass on +2 pretty pretty easily
and this is even the best move according
to the comp yeah otherwise you give up
this pawn and it's not so clear that
yeah how to how to progress after that
let's say I could I could go here but
after that it's not so so
straightforward and this is not possible
at the moment he's attacking this now
giving up the exchange is a pretty
pretty simple pretty simple win but what
I'd like to briefly check on is this are
these complications here now can play
with G area I am I really thought about
that
this was possible after that two pieces
are hanging and this yeah this is
completely completely weird let's say I
don't know we're here three I've got
three pawns for the piece but black is
probably in a very good shape yeah his
pieces don't coordinate so badly you can
castlelong
not very very unclear the black answer
probably good him okay this sound this
also means that here I should do
something else probably hmm
curious
yeah this should be a fine position for
white but it's not so evident how to
play
maybe the end connect click on the C
phone by like he's got two bishops this
is always something to reckon with
something like this trying to open up
yeah
interesting interesting I didn't really
refute his opening all right thanks for
watching